El día 1 de diciembre del 2001 es un día
que ha quedado grabado a fuego en la memoria
colectiva del pueblo argentino.
Ese día, el entonces Ministro de Economía,
Domingo Felipe Cavallo, anunciaba la puesta
en marcha de la congelación de los depósitos
bancarios, popularmente conocido como “el
Corralito”.
A partir de ese momento los argentinos no
podían sacar más de 250 pesos - en aquel
momento 250 dólares - de sus cuentas en el
banco.
Por supuesto, la reacción popular no se hizo
esperar y durante días las protestas crecieron
sin parar.
La imagen icónica que ha quedado para el
recuerdo ha sido la de grupos de personas
agrupadas frente a las sucursales y sedes
bancarias, golpeando cacerolas y exigiendo
la devolución total de sus depósitos.
Queridos amigos, amigas, el caos fue tan grande
que poco más de dos semanas después, el
20 de diciembre, el Presidente Fernando De
la Rúa se vio obligado a dimitir tras una
dura jornada de protestas en la Plaza de Mayo
que se saldó con al menos 29 personas fallecidas.
20 años después en VisualPolitik nos hemos
hecho unas cuantas preguntas: ¿Por qué se
produjo exactamente el corralito? ¿Cuáles
fueron los verdaderos motivos de la mayor
crisis económica en la historia de la Argentina?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿Existe acaso la posibilidad de que volvamos
a ver una situación similar?
Atentos.
(CAMINO AL ABISMO)
Sabéis que en VisualPolitik nos encanta la
Argentina. Y, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Creo que si algo ha quedado claro tras la
larga lista de vídeos que hemos publicado
sobre este país - con este van ya 21 -, es
la clara predilección que la Argentina tiene
por tener un gobierno gigantesco.
Y, no nos engañemos, en la práctica sólo
existen 3 formas de financiar un gobierno
gigantesco:
Una carga tributaria asfixiante;
Un endeudamiento crónico
O una descontrolada emisión monetaria.
Pues bien, a lo largo de la historia podemos
encontrar gobiernos que han tratado de gastar
a manos llenas recurriendo a una de estas
fuentes de financiación.
Sin embargo, lo particular del caso argentino
es que desde la década de 1940 prácticamente
todos los gobiernos han usado y abusado sin
tregua de estas 3 herramientas al mismo tiempo.
Eso es lo que explica la eterna crisis gaucha.
La madre de todos los males de la Argentina,
una constante de todos los gobiernos, de un
color o de otro: un gasto público inasumible.
Una política que desde los años 40, y mira
que ha llovido, lleva cosechando los mismos
resultados: crisis, crisis y crisis.
Porque, amigos, las cartas están sobre la
mesa:
(El problema con la deuda es que hay que pagarla
y refinanciarla. Y cuando no se hace, entonces
la financiación escasea y se encarece. Luego
por el lado de presión tributaria sucede
tres cuartas partes de lo mismo:
Al caer la contraerse las rentas sector privado
la recaudación termina disminuyendo a medio
plazo y además se alienta la economía informal.
Por tanto a los diferentes gobiernos no les
quedó otra que echarse en brazos de la emisión
monetaria para mantener sus políticas de
más y más gasto público.
El abuso de esta herramienta ha sido tal que
ha hecho que la inflación disparada sea un
mal crónico de la economía argentina. Una
economía que llegó a experimentar un proceso
de fortísima hiperinflación entre 1989 y
1990 que tal y como sostienen los economistas
Pablo Guido y Gustavo Lazzari esto supuso
“la muerte del dinero”.)
Tal y como os contamos, en un pasado vídeo
titulado “Cuando la Argentina quiso volver
a ser rica” el único momento dónde dio
la sensación de que realmente Argentina quería
cambiar de rumbo fue bajo los gobierno de
Carlos Saul Menem, quien de la mano de su
Ministro de Economía, Domingo Cavallo, puso
en marcha un amplio proceso de reformas, incluyendo
la privatización de buena parte de las empresas
públicas.
Sin embargo, lo que no desapareció fue la
madre de todos los males: el gasto público
disparado.
Básicamente, la única diferencia fue que
en lugar de financiarlo con inflación, esto
es, dándole una y otra y otra a la máquina
de imprimir billetes, los gobiernos de Menem
financiaron sus políticas de gasto con el
dinero procedente de las privatizaciones primero
y luego con más y más endeudamiento.
Es decir, que lo que hizo Menem fue apagar
el incendio de hiperinflación de la presidencia
de Ricardo Alfonsin, su antecesor en el cargo,
y dar un golpe de timón.
Pero no sacó adelante ni mucho menos todos
los cambios que Argentina necesitaba para
despegar:
El gasto público siguió creciendo, la apertura
con Mercosur fue muy limitada, la regulación
siguió siendo excesiva, especialmente en
lo referente a la legislación laboral - En
Argentina hacen tan difícil y costoso crear
empleo, que al final pues lógicamente no
se crea empleo, y cuando lo hace, lo hace
en la economía informal.
Fijaos cómo estaban las cosas allá por comienzos
del nuevo siglo.
(“Por cada $100 que figuran como ingreso
bruto en el recibo de un trabajador sólo
$ 82 van a su bolsillo. Mientras tanto, el
empleador por esos $100 de ingreso bruto debe
abonar $133. Esto significa que por cada $ 82
que recibe efectivamente un trabajador privado,
el empleador debe abonar $133. La diferencia,
un 62% constituye una interminable sumatoria
de impuestos. Pablo Guido y Gustavo Lazzari,
Apuntes Sobre la Economía Argentina, 2003)
[Y, ojo, porque hoy las cosas siguen igual…
O peor.]
Para colmo, volviendo a la época de Menem,
muchas de las privatizaciones se hicieron
de tal forma que crearon mercados cautivos
que se quedaron en manos de amigos del gobierno.
Las cosas mejoraron… Pero en el fondo no
tanto. Así que cuando Menem dejó el gobierno
el país seguía teniendo muchos problemas.
Los argentinos no lo sabían pero el corralito
ya se estaba gestando.
(TIK TAK)
Diciembre de 1999: Fernando De la Rúa se
convierte en el nuevo presidente de la Argentina.
La situación económica era ya en aquel momento
complicada. Era urgente hacer ajustes, por
ejemplo, para frenar el agujero, que digo
agujero, el boquete que tenían las cuentas
públicas que amenazaba con poner patas arriba
toda la economía.
El Tik Tak hacía la destrucción económica
estaba en marcha.
Y aquí, amigos, os hago una pregunta: ¿Qué
demonios pensáis que hizo de la Rúa? ¿Cómo
quiso enfrentarse al déficit público?
¿Recortando el gasto público? 3, 2,1….
Ni de broma. Hablamos de Argentina, de Argentina,
de Argentina. La propuesta del gobierno se
basó básicamente en subir los impuestos
en lugar de recortar el gasto.
De los algo más de 7.000 millones de dólares
de ajuste en el déficit público incluidos
en el plan del gobierno para 2021, casi 6.000
millones correspondián a subidas de impuestos.
Poco más de 1.000 a control del gasto. Era
una relación 80-20.
Claro, que una cosa es una propuesta política
y otra muy distinta la realidad.
Tras varias crisis políticas, en noviembre
del 2000, De la Rúa reconocía finalmente
que la disminución del déficit no sería
ni mucho menos la prevista.
Y al mes siguiente, el Congreso aprobó un
presupuesto con un déficit de 7.000 millones
de pesos, es decir 70% más de lo anunciado
por el plan inicial del gobierno.
Amigos el Tik Tak seguía en marcha y ya parecía
claro que el año 2001 sería muy difícil.
(El año 2001 fue una catástrofe. La inversión
cayó un 45%, el consumo casi un 10 y el desempleo
no paraba de subir. La tasa de paro alcanzó
el 18% y las protestas lideradas por la oposición
peronista se recrudecieron. De la Rua enfrentó
8 paros nacionales en sus dos años de gobierno,
en los que también surgieron los piquetes,
esto es, grupos organizados ligados a sindicatos
que durante sus protestas cortas las carreteras,
las calles y la actividad económica.
En semejante contexto, la desconfianza era
casi total, lo que provocó que los depósitos
bancarios se desplomaran un 20%. Nadie se
fiaba ya del futuro de la economía argentina.
Había que poner a salvo todo lo que se pudiera.)
Para intentar revertir la situación, De la
Rúa decidió colocar a un economista partidario
de ajustar el gasto público, Ricardo López
Murphy al frente del Ministerio de Economía.
Duró 15 días.
Amigos al gobierno ya solo le quedaba una
bala: echarse en brazos del padre de las reformas
de la era Menem, Domingo Felipe Cavallo.
Para mantener el gasto público se obligó
a los bancos y a los fondos de pensiones a
comprar deuda pública, al tiempo que se aprobó
un megacanje para convertir deuda a corto
plazo en deuda a largo plazo con tipos de
interés mayores. Lo que equivale a decir:
patada para adelante.
Ya lo veis, todo tipo de malabares con tal
de no meter la mano donde hacia falta: al
gasto público.
[¿Qué esperaban? ¿Que esa vez ocurriera
algo diferente? Pues... evidentemente no.]
(Era una situación imposible: el gobierno
ya no tenía activos valiosos que privatizar
y lograr dinero. La financiación internacional
estaba cerrada, el FMI dijo que sin recortes
de gasto no contaran con él; y si el gobierno
recurría a la emisión monetaria, esto es
banco central, la gente enseguida corría
a cambiar sus pesos por dólares ante lo que
pudiera pasar, lo que hacía más difícil
mantener el tipo de cambio al tiempo que se
reducían las reservas de divisas. Las cosas
iban de mal en peor.)
Ya solo quedaba esperar el estallido de la
crisis.
(LA EXPLOSIÓN)
Los argentinos sabían que la situación era
de extrema gravedad. Entre enero y noviembre
de 2001 los depósitos bancarios cayeron en
otros 20.000 millones de pesos (20.000 millones
dólares). De ellos 1.500 millones fueron
retirados de los bancos el viernes 30 de noviembre.
Era un ritmo insostenible. Así que la solución
del gobierno fue La “solución” fue decretar
un feriado bancario y restringir el retiro
de dinero de las cajas de ahorro y cuentas
corrientes.
La medida se anunció el sábado 1 de diciembre
y comenzó a regir el lunes 3. Se estableció
un límite de retiro de 250 pesos semanales
por cuenta. Es decir, si uno tenía 10.000
pesos en su cuenta solo podía acceder a 250
por semana. Y ojo, porque luego se redujo
a 2 el número máximo de cuentas que una
persona podía tener.
[Apunte: El resto del dinero se podía utilizar
por medio de tarjetas de débito u operaciones
electrónicas, pero, claro, tenemos que tener
en cuenta que a finales de 2001 eran muy poca
la gente que realizaba ese tipo de operaciones
en Argentina]
Fue el corralito.
Un corralito que según lo aprobado por el
gobierno tendría una vigencia de 90 días.
Claro que esos 3 meses fueron suficientes
para cambiar la historia del país y causar
un daño económico irreparable.
(La medida provocó el efecto opuesto al que
perseguía el gobierno. En lugar de generar
tranquilidad generó incertidumbre y caos.
La medida hundió el consumo y a muchas pequeñas
empresas, pero además los argentinos empezaban
a comprender lo que suponía perder sus ahorros
de un día para otro. Pues, por qué el fin
de la convertibilidad 1 a 1 con el dólar
iba a suponer irremediablemente una tremenda
devaluación del peso argentino, de ahí la
urgencia por sacar el dinero. O sacabas tus
ahorros o los perdías, y cómo el gobierno
no te dejaba sacarlo… Era una especie de
ruina a cámara lenta.)
El gobierno en ese momento buscó el rescate
del FMI, pero cuando Cavallo viajó a Estados
Unidos se encontró con una respuesta tajante:
[Qué no, qué no, que no nos contenéis películas.
Si no ordenáis las cuentas públicas y recortáis
el gasto público nosotros el FMI no vamos
a poner más dinero. De ninguna manera, ni
de broma.]
Pronto la situación degeneró a tal nivel
que la desesperación, los saqueos, los choques
con la policía se hicieron cotidianos. Finalmente
el 19 de diciembre, el presidente De la Rúa
ante la imposibilidad de contener las protestas
y los saqueos, decretó el Estado de Sitio:
El mismo instrumento del que se habían valido
las diferentes dictaduras militares de Argentina
para controlar a la población.
Supuso arrojar gasolina al fuego.
El 20 de diciembre los enfrentamientos con
las fuerza del orden dejaron 29 fallecidos.
El gobierno estaba acabado. Minutos antes
de las 20 horas el presidente presentaba su
renuncia y se aleja de la Casa Rosada en helicóptero.
(DOLOR Y RUINA)
De De la Rúa, el poder pasó a Ramón Puerta,
tres días después la Asamblea Legistaliva
eligió presidente al gobernador de la provincia
de San Luis, Adolfo Rodríguez Saa, quien
por cierto ostentó el cargo apenas 7 días
antes de renunciar, desde el 23 al 30 de diciembre,
período que aprovechó para declarar el default
de la deuda externa ante el aplauso unánime
de todo el Congreso.
Luego el poder cayó en manos de Eduardo Camaño
y finalmente en Eduardo Duhalde, un sindicado
que había alentado las protestas y que asumió
el 1 de enero de 2002.
En menos de 10 días la Argentina tuvo 5 jefes
de estado diferentes. Fueron las horas más
negras.
Durante los siguientes meses la pobreza se
multiplicó, el peso se siguió devaluando
y pasó de 1:1 a 1:3, los depósitos no se
devolvieron, a los que tenían dólares en
el banco se los robaron y se los cambiaron
por pesos que cada vez valían menos.
Por supuesto todo esto supuso el fin del peso
y del sistema financiero argentino. Nadie
en su sano juicio volvería a dejar sus ahorros
en manos de los políticos.
20 años después Argentina sigue en las mismas.
El país está más endeudado que nunca, tiene
la mayor presión impositiva de su historia
y la inflación anual supera el 50%.
Es lo que ya se conoce como la tragedia argentina.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
en esta ocasión voy a ser crudo y directo
¿Crees que la Argentina tiene solución?
Si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un abrazo a todos los que nos veis desde la
Argentina.